Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday. Uh,
December 26th, 2016 what's going on?
how are ya. Oh my God.
It's the last Monday of fucking 2016.
Um, George Michael passed away on Christmas Day.
Um, wake me up before you'd go go, uh,
condolences to him. And uh,
you know what the best thing about 2016 being over is, is, um,
you know longer,
you're gonna have to listen to people blaming a year for bad things happening.
You know, it's a big thing. Fuck you. 2016.
I saw Madonna tweeted that. Fuck you. 2016.
Fuck you. You fucking year man. You know,
why do people keep blaming the fucking year? You know,
it has nothing to do with the fucking year you're talking to. There's this,
people's genetics are involved. There's a lifestyle choices.
There's substance abuse. I mean, that's what's going on here.
I don't know why you're a, you know, we're picking on 2016 like,
it's a, a religion from the Middle East or something.
I have no fucking idea how it's getting the blame for all of this.
You know what I mean? Fucking 2016 with your liver cancer,
you know, let's blame 2016 rather than the pharmaceutical companies.
That fucking was given out opiates like Flintstone vitamins and created a
fucking heroin epidemic. Fuck all of that.
Okay.
2016 has robbed us of some of the greatest artists of our time.
2016 he did like, it's a fucking person.
How to fucking Madonna. Madonna is world traveled.
She's been around the fucking world.
Whoever you talked to enough people to not know to blame a fucking year. Well,
maybe she's saying that metaphorically, Bill. I don't give a shit.
Okay.
You know, if I try to see her side of the things,
how can I come up with the comedic angle to try to fill out this next fucking 60
minutes? Fuck you. 2016 oh yeah.
You didn't like seeing the cubs finally win a world series. Ah,
nothing good happened to you this year. You just gonna focus on the bad.
Yeah.
Anyways. I like people also then try to have like a religious thing,
like when a prince is backup dancers had this whole fucking religious thing that
she went on saying like, you know, like wake up people, you know,
that's, that's when you know, you're out of your fucking mind. You know,
when you start telling people to wake up like, like you're,
you're reading the fucking, uh,
you're reading the tea leaves better than anybody else in your fucking,
you know, garrison colonial, wherever the fuck you live,
wake up people he capital h is,
is taking a, it's robbing us of some of our greatest artists.
You know,
like that's a sign. Like all these, these great musicians are leaving us,
which means like what?
Okay.
Like Jesus is mad at all the fucking plumbers and electricians and shit.
Granted, they fucking overcharge you and they, they,
they lie about when the date, the date of whatever's going to be done,
the job's going to be done.
Um, yeah. I don't fucking know. I mean,
I don't understand. I understand blaming them fucking year.
You know,
dude,
I just can't wait for this year to be over and then it's going to be 2017 I'm
not going to do any work on myself and I'll basically make the same fucking
decisions I made in 2016 but somehow 2017 is gonna be better without me having
to make any effort whatsoever.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ. I mean,
why don't you just get out your rosary and say all your fucking prayers rather
than fucking making a positive step towards trying to make a real change.
Um,
anyway, so let's talk about that Madonna thing. When she was shaking her folks,
she was talking with that fucking woman, Jesus Christ. Unbelievable.
I just like, I hate that she does that because it makes me feel old.
You know,
when she, she was all hot say [inaudible]. Anyway, so let's plow ahead.
This is not, this is not why I wanted to do this thing here. Um,
did you guys have a nice holiday? Did you have a nice Kirwan Zoo?
Did you have a nice Chat Hanukkah? Did you have a nice Christmas there, Joe?
Hey Jewish people do. Do you guys like how many you actually, uh,
when I was a kid,
people who weren't Jewish told me how you guys celebrate Hanukkah.
And I realized, well they weren't really Jewish. Were there,
let me ask you this. Do you, do you do,
how many people do the traditional thing?
Is it a one day thing or is it like a nine day thing?
How many candles are on the manure? Is that the same as a baseball team?
And if so, do you give fucking one gift a day for nine days?
Like total old school, you know,
we're baking our own bread here type of thing, right? Is that our actually,
is that a religious story? Isn't that there's always bread.
There's always bread, there's always fish. There's a fucking leper, you know?
And then there's always the one guy, Abraham Mohammad or Jesus, right.
Hog it up the whole fucking budget.
Like the same way they make movies nowadays we're Tom Cruise gets all the
fucking money, right? He gets all the fucking money.
And what about those character actors? I go fuck yourself. Right? You know,
back in the day you could, you could make a living as a character actor.
You know what I mean? Not any more. That's not how it works.
Okay?
Not In the age of, uh, the fucking superhero movies. So anyways,
let me see how many days of Hanukkah. Why don't we, why don't we look this up?
Happy Hanukkah. Happy Hanukkah. All right.
How many days in a Nuka he's eight days a days.
A week. All right, so it's eight days. I'm sorry. Nine guys on a baseball team.
Eight days a Hanukkah. Do you fucking give a gift?
Every deaths the traditional way as far as the non Jewish people told me that
they give a gifted date. Now if you do that, my question, my question to you is,
how do you give out those gifts? You know, how do it,
do you do it? Like how I do is stand up set? Well,
you gotta start with something strong.
You got to establish that you're the fucking man for the job, right?
I don't mean to be sexist about that, but when you really think about it,
men do a better fucking job just generally speaking.
You know what I mean? Women have been nowhere near the fucking moon. Okay,
okay.
And we were there like, fucking how many of you, I don't,
I'm fucking years ago where we, you know, oh Jesus. I just felt,
I just thought of one of the worst fucking jokes ever. And I will not say it,
but I'll describe it to you. Okay. I will describe it to him.
I can't do it. I can't, I,
the only way to get away with it is if Nia is here also laughing.
I was going to say, you put the guys out in the space, you know,
we get all the way to the moon. You know, you try to bring a lady up there,
right? You see where I'm going? I can't do that. It's a day after Christmas.
I would not do that. Um, anyways, eight days. So what do you do?
Do you start off with the fucking something strong? You know,
and then you establish like this is the little level of gift giving and you
gradually start your ascent through days. Two, three, four, five, six. Whoa,
whoa. We're going into another level. Seven and then eight.
You gave him the all A's you fucking gift now fuck off for a year.
That's how I would do it if I was Jewish. All right.
Me and Nia were Jewish and I had to get Niyah eight gifts. All right.
What would I start off with? I'd start off with some shoes, right?
Cause bitches be loving the Jews, right?
I gave her the fucking some shoes then a Jesus Christ.
Fucking eight gifts.
Okay.
Yeah, we got to go. Go close. No, you know what?
I would start right out of the gate. I'd start with something silly.
You know like her stock had stuff for this year. Like I know like she, you know,
certain kinds of foods she likes. Like one year I told her, like I said,
I know I'm going to get you for Christmas. She goes, well you get [inaudible],
I'm getting you a bag of Fritos. Right. She just kept laughing. You know,
thinking it was the funniest thing ever that I wasn't actually going to do it.
So of course the first gift I gave her, she opened it up,
it was a bag of Fritos and I gave her a big bear hug and I was like,
oh this is the greatest Christmas ever.
And she thought it was the funniest fucking thing ever. So if we would Joe et,
what I would do, I would start off with stupid fucking gifts.
Cause who's kidding who? I'm not going fucking broke here. All right.
Is a Christian a non practicing Christian?
I don't get my wife eight gifts a year. You know what I mean?
Okay
Dude, you guys should do it like a game show. Okay.
Do you want a pretty good gifts? Uh, one fucking great one.
That's like when you win the lottery,
do you want get it all at once or have get paid a hundred grand over 20 years.
And anybody who always takes the payments doesn't understand money. And also,
you know, it's just like, well don't go, don't we all once I'm going to blow it.
You get it all at once even though you were in a bigger tax bracket.
You know what I mean?
It gets you over the hump into being a fucking millionaire.
I don't give a fuck how much money you make. If they give you 200 grand a year,
you're never going to get up over the million cause they're going to fuck it.
They're going to tax the shit out of you
if you take it all at once roughly.
I mean you could do it if you just fucking sat there eating corn flakes and
shit. But like if you take it all at once and then you invest it,
but you're not going to know what to do and they wasn't there a whole
documentary on that. I have no idea.
But my wife fortunately liked to give, so she gave me this year and you know,
it was funny,
I made fun of getting socks for Christmas and she got me socks that she was all
embarrassed. She goes,
you sent it on Thursday that you didn't like saying I like socks,
I'm just fucking around. That was,
that was the only thing in my stocking this year, she bought me a little box,
three pairs came in this little box. It literally was going to be cookies.
I opened it up with some tape,
Baker tape his socks and I don't give a fuck. You know what I mean? Okay.
Sediment adults, you can give me a Choo Choo train. Silver. It's fucking over.
Um, so anyways, um, okay,
I'll tell you this quick story. Fortunately,
Nia lights her gifts and I always have a little bit of anxiety whenever I give
him the gifts because, uh, first my first girlfriend I ever had,
I think I told you this story before, did I? Um,
my first girlfriend I ever had, I had to get her a gift.
Now I didn't grow up around the ladies.
I just had brothers for the longest fucking time. Right.
And I don't mean black people. I mean, I mean I had like,
I was related to these people. I had brothers. Um,
so, um, this cough is never going to go away by the way,
cause the fuckin prescription I got, you know,
just fucking put it down on the mat and now it's just fucking hanging around
like this thing that won't leave. I know you guys are thinking, oh,
he must be smoking like a chimney. I'm not, I'm not fucking smoking at all. Uh,
slash I might be done with cigars. Um,
and I'm Kinda, I'm kinda done with booze too.
I just can't fucking do it anymore. You know, I love it and all that shit,
but I just hate waking up in the morning like, ugh. Like I'm over,
I'm over hangovers. Fuck you. 20, 60. Um,
yeah, I'll have like a beer. I'll, I'll have like, you know, uh,
like one glass of Scotch at this point, but I can't do the fucking, uh,
I can't take the ride anymore. You know what I mean?
And it just hit me one day, like, you know how quickly Brett Farve got old,
just Bam, done over out of the fucking league. You know,
he hung around and he hung around and he hung around.
Then he took that last fucking hit when he was on the Vikings. You know,
it just looked like his clothes were just laying on the ground for,
didn't even believe there was a person, you know,
and all the really religious people got all concerned that you know,
that they get left behind and it's like, no,
that's what it looks like when a fucking 42 year old guy takes a hit from my
fucking defense event. Um, yeah,
I'm fucking done within all of that shit. Uh, however,
let me tell you this story. The first girlfriend ahead, so it was,
her birthday was coming up and um,
I had absolutely no idea what to get a, uh, a female.
So I go to the mall and I'm looking around, I'm looking around,
I had no fucking idea.
And I came up to this table and they had all these polo style shirts,
nice shirts, shirt I would wear,
and they were on sale and all that stuff and it just,
all these different colors.
So I bought her like four of them and I wrapped him up and I gave them to her
izods and Polo shirts and shit.
And she fucking unwrapped these things and the level of disappointment on her
face. And she just was like, what? What is, what is this?
What the fuck and do? She just fucking went off. She flipped out,
she started yelling at me like, like a, you know,
like a head coach mad at halftime, you know, you know, I said, kick the ball,
my Tony Jacket, you know, flipping out on me. And I literally did,
I was so embarrassed. I like kind of put my head down.
I looked at my feet and then just sat down on the edge of the bed as she was
yelling at me. Right. And, uh,
I dunno what happened. Like I was so fucking embarrassed and she, you know,
was young.
I didn't know anything about women and Shit and she was just going off on me and
about three quarters of the way into her rent,
which was really a good 90 seconds long, by the way, which is fucking forever.
I think she was kind of coming to her senses that she was taking in what she was
doing to me by my body language and the fact that she had just given,
gotten a gift and the way she was reacting and, uh,
she started to try to pull back on the stick and be like, ah, no, you know,
it's Kinda, and that's when the anger fucking hit me.
That was one of the first times in my ute that, um,
I actually address my feelings in the moment. You know,
I was fucking one of those people brutally. Like three days later I'd be like,
Hey, wait a minute.
That person took advantage of me or that person was being rude.
I should've fucking said something. Right. Um,
this fucking wave of anger came up and, uh, I just, you know,
handle it classically like the German Irish guy. I am,
I didn't communicate anything. I just stood up. I walked over,
I started putting my jacket on and all that. Now of course she's fucking, no,
don't leave doing all that shit. You know what I mean?
And all you want to do is the, you know, the, you know,
the swim move that a defensive lineman does. You know,
you fucking pushed to the side and then you fucking bring your arm up and over.
That's what I wanted to do. So of course,
now I'm walking towards the door and she does what all,
what every fucking woman does in that moment.
She's blocking the door and now she's crying. She's crying, you know,
it's like, what are you crying about after everything you just said to me?
I'm holding it together pretty fucking good here. So she's crying.
Now she's between the door and I say, you know, I want to leave.
I'm leaving, I'm leaving. No, blah, blah, blah. Look, you know, and then that,
then they said awful thing.
They standing there whole none of the fucking door jam and you can't put your
hands on them or else you're going to go to fucking jail.
Even if you're just trying to remove it. So weird. You know what I mean?
It's like you're a human being. You want to leave the room that you're in,
you're in a free country.
There's another human being preventing you from doing it there.
They're holding you there against your fucking will, but they're a fucking lady,
so it's totally fine. So what do you do?
You just have to sit there and not looking them in the eye.
Just staring at the fucking door. Like I'm fucking leaving.
You can stand here as long as you want. I am going to fucking leave. Right,
Ms. Brutally key. You can't,
you can't put your hands on and you can't even try to like, you know,
with the outside of your arms. So to try to, you know,
kind of shoehorn your way past them. Um,
cause then they start flailing around like deliberately trying to get themselves
hurt during the altercation.
So then you feel bad and then you won't fucking leave. They're fucking loaded.
Ticks. I wanna leave. Right. Look at me. It's still bugs me.
So, you know, and I swear to God, you know,
I've always wanted to come up with something that you could sell for 1995 late
at night and all these mouth breeds and fucking morons that think Trump's going
to make the fucking planet great again or fucking or United States great again
and all these fucking dumb brides.
I thought that because Hillary also had a vagina,
that somehow their life was going to improve those fucking morons. Right?
As yet another day of disappointment has gone past and they fill themselves up
with buying absolute shit for 1995 I've always thought,
how can I take advantage of these people for $20 a pop? And I've, you know,
every time I've come up with something,
I find out somebody else's already invented it.
Like I came up with this fucking thing that, you know,
you stick between the car seat and the console,
so every time you drop something, it doesn't go between the seats.
Someone already came up with that, right?
That was the only thing that I ever came up with,
but somebody already came up with it.
So it'd be great if for like 1995 you could come up with a device that gets the
woman away from the fucking door so you can fucking leave when they're blocking
it would,
that does not involve like hurting them or her at any point.
Also being able to say that you put your hands on. So I figured there's like,
I don't know. I know what you have.
Like you have like giant fucking like these nerf hands. Okay.
And you just put 'em on either side of her. Right. Then once you stick them on,
they just stick on. Like,
you know when they have like those plastic explosives that you just slap on the
side of a tank. It's like once they on you, they're fucking on you.
You're going to owe her a new shirt. All right. But at the end of the day,
that's worth, worth the fucking price of just getting the fuck out of there.
Okay. So you put them on either side of her and then you have, you know,
those blood pressure pumps as a, you
xxxxxx that she can't fucking move, you know, and then, yeah. Then you, you,
you got an inflatable BBA, right? And then you just guide her over.
You put her down on the fucking bean bag, you open the door,
and then you fucking bring the blood pressure pump just to the outside of the
door. You close the door and right as your, by ready to close it,
you release it, see closed the door, and then you fucking run to your car,
right?
You know that day where you're fucking running and you feel lightheaded in shit
and she's going to be come running down the hall after you.
Now it's like you're in a horror movie.
You're trying to get your keys out in here. She fucking comes.
You get in the fucking car of,
hopefully you get the car door close before that fucking lunatic comes up to
stick her fucking arm and you close the door, you lock it,
and then you know what she's going to do.
She's going to stand behind your fucking car.
Then all you do is you just start the car right? And you rev the fucking engine.
Get those admissions in her face. You listen to some tunes.
Eventually she's going to have to go to the bathroom and who knows?
Maybe an hour later, maybe a fucking hour later, you know,
you get the fuck out of there.
Bye.
1995 I can put that in infomercial, not even infomercial. That's too much money.
I can do that in a fucking 32nd spot, right?
Fellas?
Have you ever wanted to leave your girlfriend's apartment but she won't let you?
What do you do? You've tried moving her out of the way, right? She yells,
fucking rape that the cops come in and fucking tackle you and show you in a cell
with a fucking giant cellmate looking at you like he's going to bang you in the
ass. Right?
That's the first six seconds of the commercial and I think you guys can do the
rest of it. Maybe that's a reason to have a four wheel drive vehicle.
So when she's like, uh, standing behind, you can't back out.
You just put it in drive. Go right up and over a curb. I don't know.
I guess what I'm really getting at here is I hope you guys all enjoyed your
holidays. Your Nice fucking days off here.
You know, I spent so long since I've had a day job yet.
Do you guys have to go back to work today? That sucks, man. You know,
the day after Christmas, you write back and then let's see, what is it?
New Year's Day is what? It's Sunday.
Yeah. News days. Sunday. But then they played the bowl games on Monday.
So maybe next weekend you get the fucking three day weekend. I have no idea.
All I can say is fuck you. 2016.
Glad this year's over man. Um, you know,
a while ago when they came up with the college football playoffs,
somebody play off. Somebody asked me to comment on it. Um,
and I was too fucking busy editing to the goddamn show.
I'd never really looked at it. Um,
and it just dawned on me that Ohio state is in and Penn state is out.
How the fuck does that work?
Okay,
somebody please explain that to me.
Okay.
Penn State won the big 10 championship and they beat Ohio state.
Penn state's in the fucking Rosebowl and Ohio State's in the playoff.
I've got a friend of mine who's a buckeyes fans and he's bitching about Alex
[inaudible],
Bam, Oh dude, who these, these schedule
as fuck. And he's whining. It's like, dude, you shouldn't even be in there.
Okay.
Iowa state should not fucking be in there.
That makes no fucking sense whatsoever. And all you fucking cons.
Who are going to go will Alabama had a real easy schedule. Sec sucked this year.
So what sec was there?
The whole fucking year was basically playing a national championship game like
fucking two, three times. They, the conference was that good for 10 years?
Alabama had to fight through all of that. So one time they get an easy year.
Um, yeah. Anyways, having said that,
I'm still rooting against them cause you have to, they're so fucking good.
It's fun. It's fun. And I told you my favorite thing in sports,
Alabama down at the half.
And then Nick Saban has to talk to one of those sideline reporter women.
You know, all he wants to do is fucking slam some lockers,
is chew out his punter or some shit. And he's got to sit there.
Like I'm telling you, if anything is going to put that guy in an early grave,
it's that fucking interview we asked to do. Um, so anyways, yeah, I don't,
I mean I'm not like Anti Ohio state, but that does,
that does not seem fair to me at all.
How does a team that didn't win the big 10,
it didn't even win their fucking conference championship is in the final four.
It's all bullshit. It's all fucking money. It's all money.
Iowa state is going to get better ratings.
I bet it's going to give them better ratings than fucking Penn state.
Other than that, it makes no fucking sense on paper. You know?
And I love those kids that are going to sit out there ballgame and every,
but he's just like, Whoa, what the fuck
sports talk radio guys. It's like, dude, it's fucking slave labor.
Remember that dude on Ohio state played that fucking Penn state. Uh,
was it Willis from a gay, he got his fucking knee blown out for free.
Caused him a career in the NFL. If he didn't have such a great fucking agent,
um, yeah. Fuck you. You're going to sell,
sell a Jersey with the kid's name on it. You're going to make millions more.
The fucking players are selling out 100,000 seat and don't get a fucking dime.
Figure that one out.
Okay?
All those players throughout the fucking century of the damn team that have
created the excitement gone out there, blown out their knees,
got concussions, got paralyzed, died early fucking deaths.
Do not get one dime. Fuck you and your ballgame.
They got to start giving these kids money, man. It's fucking brutal.
It's brutal.
I love all the fucking nerds that actually go to class and they get mad at the
athletes because they don't show up. It's like, hey fucking,
if it wasn't for that kid out there, you would,
you would have a class in a tent right now. You know,
what do you think paid for this? This fucking biology classroom,
Huh?
People show up 100,000 people showing up to look at you.
Look through a fucking microscope. It didn't, all right.
You don't have a sexy job deal with it. Right.
I don't get it. Having said that, I'm still going to watch and I'm,
I dunno, I like Clemson too, but uh, I don't know. I'm kind of a big 10 guy too.
I probably still root for house state, but that, that's so fun.
It doesn't make any fucking sense. I mean,
there's always going to be a reason to complain because football's such a
violent game that they can't have like march madness.
They just can't be too many fucking games and too many kids getting hurt. Right.
So every year someone's going to get mad and a,
so I usually blow it off, but this year Penn State got fucked.
You know? I mean, maybe it's leftover San Dusky Shit. You know what I mean?
Like not enough time has gone by.
I'm just going to pause here to listen to all the Penn state fans go. Ah,
you know, it's funny.
Is the fucking Tom Brady deflate gate story lasted longer than that sent Dusky
Shit. And that's the world that we live in. Fuck you.
Um, all right, let's get to some of the questions here for this week shall we?
Um,
okay.
Oh, how about the fucking Celtics man, that's Celtics Knicks game was great.
The NBA too, by the way. Bravo for saying, all right, NFL,
you get thanksgiving, we get Christmas.
They actually muscled the NFL out a position on a football Sunday to the point
that all the fucking games are on Saturday, Saturday.
Were there any NFL games yesterday? I didn't even look.
The NBA Games was so fucking great. I missed the first one.
I watched the Celtics and Nick's great fucking game then we almost blew it.
And here's the funny thing is Michael Rappaport still owes me dinner from the
NBA finals and that cause he's a cheat motherfucker or anything.
It's cause we're both fucking busy and we just,
we run into each other like once every six months. So Celtics,
the play in Nicks on Christmas Day. And I saw, I texted him, I said, Hey Mike,
you want to go double enough and I'll take the Celtics straight up. And he goes,
absolutely. And then he goes, wait, he goes, so if,
if I lose, do I owe you two dinners? I go, no, you owe me breakfast.
You owe me dinner and now you owe me breakfast.
And then we'll bet on the Superbowl and if I win, you know, if you, if you win,
you don't owe me shit. And if I, when you owe me breakfast,
lunch and dinner and you're going to fucking take me out,
we're going to do a youtube video of you taken me out on the town for the entire
fucking day. And uh, so he said, all right, so he's in.
So what I'm hoping is that there's going to be a Patriot's giants fucking the
trilogy.
And of course I'm taking my patriots and I'm hoping this is the year that our
defense doesn't let Tom Brady down.
Cause the first two times we played the giants,
He drove them at the Patriots down the field for the go ahead score. Both Times.
He has six for six in Superbowls.
When it is counted right,
the time would Dunavan McNabb fucking throws up.
Neil O'Donnell throws a pick paint, manning throws a pick six.
Tom Brady has manned up all six.
He's gone six and o unfortunately his defense has gone forward too.
Um, so I want to see that rematch.
And um, of course I'm going to take the Patriots and I texted him,
I said, okay, so patriots and giants play each other.
What's going to happen? Are the Patriots going to go oh and three?
No.
The giant's going to go out and say that the giant is going to go three and no
against the Patriots. Or is Michael Rappaport going to go oh,
in three against the menu. So, um, hopefully that's going to happen.
You know, I want the Patriots to play. We'd go back to super.
We have to play the fucking charts. I don't give a fuck about Seattle.
We already played them. We already beat them.
I don't give a fuck about anybody else. We gotta we gotta go back.
You got to do it. You know, I talked to some fucking patriots. Fans are like,
oh my God, that makes me sick to my stomach. So what are you gonna do?
You're gonna quit.
Now you're gonna put your Paul revere hat between your fucking legs and go home.
You know, I think the biggest thing this year as they, as their coach,
even though their coaches doing like a good job and everything, but you know,
I don't know, I just though this is so stupid, I just look at a coach,
I judge a book by its cover and I just look at that guy and I'm just like, yeah,
you know, I'm not feeling, I'm not feeling this guy. This guy just looks like a,
it looks like a die giants fan. That's what he looks like.
He does not look like a a head coach.
Um, so anyways, we shall see. And I told you I'm not buying into, I don't,
I don't buy, I'm not, I don't believe in the cowboys. I don't like their coach.
I look at them, I'm like, I do not, I just don't like that guy.
Not like personally don't like him.
I just look at him and he just doesn't look at your head coach
like a head coach. You gotta look at them. You gotta be like, aw man,
I would not want to get yelled at by that guy.
I know what you guys are thinking. What about p Carol?
P Carol looks like he's going to Bible study. Yeah,
but if you look into p Carol has shark eyes. Okay.
I'm telling you that fucking guy, you know,
I'm not trying to put rumors out there,
but if that guy had like a dead hooker in his past, okay. Or at least, you know,
one that lost consciousness and he brought her around, you know,
it would not surprise me.
That is so fucked up to say, I'm sure he's a hell of a guy. All right,
let's get, um, let's, uh,
let's do some of the advertising here for the lads here for the weaker, right.
Um, all right. CSO, everybody. CSO is the place for comedy.
Uh, they won't tell you how amazing they are, but I will see. So is amazing.
It's comedy for comedy nerds by comedy nerd.
CSO Spelled S. E. E. S. O. N. It is the new ad free streaming service.
Bring you original series,
handpick classic weeks of standup specials in more bingeable comedy anytime,
anywhere on CSO, every episode of SNL,
including new episodes the day they air the tonight show,
starring Jimmy Fallon and the end late date with Seth Myers,
the day after air. And they even have classics like 30 Rock, uh,
parks and recs saved by the bell.
Even British comedies like the original office were Frickey Jervais case.
He's drinking a beer. Oh my God.
The entire money python catalog,
the it crowd and Steve Coogan as Alan Partridge.
Am I supposed to know who the fuck that is? Steve Coogan has Alan Partridge.
No Way. That's his better as I Harry Hamill is Steve Rabinovitz,
critically acclaimed originals and exclusive content like Harmon quests created
by comedian Dan Harmon and funny as hell a variety show featuring comedians such
as Jim Jefferies and Hannibal Burris. If you're serious about comedy,
you've got to try CSOs streaming anytime, anywhere and for. All right.
Let's get to the point he a CSO was ad-free and just three 99 per month.
That's less than you paid for the, uh,
that latte or artisan cold brewed coffee you're holding right now.
And right now my listeners can try c. So for free for two months,
when you use the Promo Code Burra checkout, uh,
shows you can't get anywhere else from critically acclaimed original series to
all 40 years of SNL. Dude,
fucking how much money he's Lauren Michael's making off of this
get tonight show starring Jimmy Fallon.
That's one of his boys late night with Seth Meyers.
It's one of his boys 30 rock. That's one of his girls parks and recs.
That's one of his girls saved by the belt. I don't know.
He's probably got something with screech.
Just go to cso.com right now to sign up for two months for free with the Promo
Code [inaudible] at checkout. That's seeso.com promo code bar. Ah,
here we go.
But it will do to me on these Mian d he's wearing them after Christmas,
but it would do to me. [inaudible] you know,
want to fucking miss this. Does that rhyme?
Okay.
Your fucking balls will fill. Nice. I got nothing this week.
I don't know where it, why did I pick Christmas? Let's start. Take two.
Take two. Write me on these. Me On these soft as Sanchez beard.
[inaudible] due to me on these BMDS. No one will call you.
Queered when you have his beard up against you,
not sees Robyn on your tastes and your asses,
you'll feel great during the holidays. Skipping around,
returning the gifts that you didn't like. All right, me undies.
Okay.
Picture a world we're putting on a pair of underwear isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a better day. Think about it. Underwear.
It's the first thing you put on in the last thing you take off.
Unless you Matthew mcconaughey,
why would you settle for anything less than the best selling best feeling
underwear on the planet.
A Mandy's focuses solely on producing the most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced. Every dental he doesn't ride up. And your s there. My friends too,
who I've never met.
How somehow we're friends at [inaudible] sent me a few pairs a while back. Oh,
what you want?
You think that's all you gotta do to become friends with me on that superficial?
Um,
it really makes each day better when you wear this underwear for the price of
two cocktails, cocktails, Mandy's,
we'll deliver your new favorite pair of underwear right to your doorstep.
Try them on if they're not the most comfortable,
best feeling underwear you've ever had, that refund you.
Let the keep the first pair for free.
Included in the included in the price is the sweet touch of modal,
a special bent motel, a special fabric made it the best in class.
Raw materials that are scientifically proven to be three times softer than
cotton.
That's Uber Cozy undies are sold exclusively on the [inaudible] website where
you'll enjoy shipping for free in the US and Canada.
All right.
And for a limited time. Everyone,
everyone in my audience gets 20% off their first order,
but you have to go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash pur with the Mandy's better day. Guarantee. A,
you have nothing to lose. So don't wait any longer.
Go to me and he stopped slash for right now and for 20% off your first order.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash bar Jesus fucking Christ.
Those ads are so overwritten. Um, all right, hold on one second.
All right, I'm back. I'm back finally to fucking clean my God damn throat.
You know what happens? I woke up this morning, but dude, we do dude.
And I just started doing the podcast cause I've got to do much of shit today as
always, as always.
A hey Billy Balden Billy Ball. Dan,
do you get it? Billy balding business. Billy Ball. Dan His brother.
I heard you ranting about how New England keeps offloading defense defending
players. You're half right, but this year is a big year for salary cap.
What do you mean? I'm half right?
Name One person that is finished their fucking career with the Patriots on the
defensive side since fucking uh,
yeah.
Teddy Bruschi or fucking Willie McGinest.
Okay.
We never keep them. I'm not half right dude.
Richard Seymour lawyer Malloy Thai law. Uh,
who's a big fucking um, oh my God,
I can't believe we forgot his fucking name cause they're only with us for a few
years. Who is the Big Fat Guy? Our nose tackle. He's gone.
I don't know.
Anyways, he said you're half right. Dante, hightower.
Malcolm Butler are both in their mid twenties and in contracts years expect both
of them get big contracts in the off season. I don't expect that.
I don't expect that at all. Maybe one of them will.
So what you're saying is I'm half right. You're saying expect them.
So on your forecast, I'm telling you what has happened.
You're saying on your forecast that what you are you,
what you are projecting that that's, that's one of your points. Okay.
Your first point is out the fucking window. All right.
That's science fiction there. Okay.
Expect to see both of them get big contracts in the off season. Patrick Chung,
the strong safety is 30 now and we have a great young backup in Landon Collins
who is also in a contract year. Okay.
So expect Patrick Chung to get the fucking evo because he's 30 and now we'll
probably be like, hey, I'm a veteran. I play in this league.
I've demonstrated that I can do the job and that's when they go. Okay,
fucking see you later. Finally, the pro bowl, free safety,
Devin McCourty is getting top dollar dollar. So it isn't just the offense.
Okay. So in all of that shit you just said,
you only named one guy who's getting top dollar.
Okay. Everything else was projecting shit. Right.
Hope that brings some clarity to Billy Superbowl's pre-trade deadline move
sending Jamie Collins,
another middle linebacker entering a contract year who was underperforming
compared to hightower. Thanks for a great podcast. Underperforming.
All right. Whatever. Well like how you,
I like [inaudible] you ignored a Chandler Jones who's having a fucking pro bowl
year with Arizona.
Okay.
Um, you basically told me that Devin McCord is getting paid.
That's basically what you told me. And um,
they've always paid guys who are in their mid twenties, when I'm talking about,
is that next contract, that next one. They're like, yeah,
get the fuck out of here. You add a Patrick Chung,
get the fuck outta here. All right. Um, here we go.
I mean, look, as much as I'm complaining it is working,
but it does get frustrating to see these guys that just shut down this side of
the field in every couple of years. We get rid of that. Right.
Okay. And, um,
like I always feel like, you know what, I always feel like our defense,
you know,
sense the McGuinness variable and Teddy Bruschi years,
I always feel like it goes in, it's like my pie, it looks like it's done,
but inside it's still soupy, you know? So when we go up against the giants,
I just feel like we don't know. Those two times we went up again,
we didn't match up well against them. They had a monster defense.
You know, we're coming in there. You know, we had Leanna,
I just, I dunno, I love I, that's why I love the giants.
I love the giants cause they always have a great fucking defense.
I always have a great fucking defense. I that, you know,
that's why I like to steal Steelers back in the day,
that doomsday defensive cow where's you got to love those teams, you know,
cause then your offense can just be like good and you're going to win the
fucking game. That's how fucking Mark Sanchez, everybody will ask.
They started calling them Sanchez. They fucking defense was great.
Then they lost everybody and all of a sudden, you know,
uh, USC boy there didn't, couldn't just manage the game.
He at nanny had to play from behind. He's like, Eh, where do I go?
Where do I go?
And he runs right into the fucking ass of his linemen and got a concussion.
Well, you would've got a concussion. No, he probably didn't get a concussion.
That guy probably did too many squats. His ass was probably like an elbow.
Alright. Podcast inspired girlfriend to quit job that was making her miserable.
Oh Jesus Christ. This should be on the Oprah Winfrey network or we are.
We actually going to have like a feel good fucking story here.
Fuck is going on with these blinds. Open the blinds. Okay.
What did we get here? 40 minutes in. Okay.
Somebody's got to stretch this shit into another 20 minutes of ignorance. Okay.
I've been, well, Bill, you've been doing great for the first 40 minutes.
All right.
Podcast inspired girlfriend to quit job that was making her miserable.
Hey Billy bilichick. Um,
my girlfriend and I love the podcast and we listened to it together.
Whenever we're on a long road trip.
A few months ago we put on your interview with Joe Rogan, uh,
when you guys started talking about jobs you hated and how you knew, uh,
and how you had to, to know when to walk.
My girlfriends started crying. Oh, Jesus. Up to that point,
I knew that she had issues with their job,
but had no idea that our company was putting it through so much grief. Um,
so much grief that it was making her absolutely miserable deep down inside.
Once you heard the interview it convinced and inspired her to take action as
quickly as possible to seek new employment. Good for her.
Yeah and that's a great habit to get into and you do it when you fucking young
cause you don't have any kids, no wife, no husband, no mortgage.
That's when you fucking make you moves.
I'm not to say you can't do it after that but it's obviously um,
you know the there's, there's no reason not to do it when you're young. Okay.
Now she's on the right track for really great job and the possibilities of a
permanent hire with a really good companies seem to be in the works of seem to
be in the works. Knock on wood,
I would like to personally thank you and Mr Rogan for not only providing us with
great entertainment but also inadvertently helping out someone I truly love and
care about to seek a positive work environment. Dude,
is there going to be anything I could make fun of in this?
This is just like a nice letter. She is also,
she is already in better spirits than ever before and it's in part thanks to
you. Hope to see you come through the Carolina's next time around.
Thanks again and have a wonderful holiday. Well that's great.
All I can do is reiterate. I can't remember what the fuck I said, but yeah.
Um, you know, I, I had a friend of mine that was working for, uh,
was working for the Nestle Company, I think it was Nestle.
He's one of those fucking corporations and they will run in this person ragged.
And I literally watched this person go from a positive person to somebody that I
started to avoid his phone calls because like it was getting so fucking
negative. And then, uh, one day this person just said,
fuck this,
quit and actually started working for like a nonprofit and was happy as fucking
hell and is now back in the corporate world at a company that he fucking loves
in. Like, you have to fucking do them, man. You know,
that whole fucking fear of like, you know,
how am I going to pay for Shit?
We'll keep you in these bad relationships with these horrific fucking companies.
Right. Um, but what she had,
you have to always be willing to sacrifice for your own happiness.
And if that involves downsizing your fucking life and just getting,
just looking at all this shit on your shelves and all of this stuff that you
fucking have, it'd be like, how much of this shit do I even fucking need?
Cause I'm sitting here, you know,
in our guests room where I have all my drum videos, my magazines,
all these fucking books, they've just sat on the shelf for fucking years.
Like if you literally took everything off of this fucking shelves.
Okay. Other than the sentimental value of a few fucking things, I wouldn't even,
you can empty all the fucking,
those little cabinets if you emptied all of it other than when I walked in and I
didn't see it, I wouldn't miss any of it. Um,
except for I have the 1970 is in 1972.
It's the most expensive years of football cards. Um,
I have the complete set that I would miss that I witness.
There's a couple other things I got up there. But other than that, I, you know,
I'm, you know what? I'm going to get rid of all that fucking shit.
I'm gonna downsize my fuck. But I'm saying you can do that.
Think about when you first fucking, you know, moved out of your house.
What did you have? You had to close on your back. Couple pieces. Shit,
things have furniture, right? And then other than that, just over the years,
you get subscriptions to magazines. You say that you start collecting shit.
People give you stuff,
you go and fucking trips and you buy shot glasses and then all of a sudden what
you really yet your house is just this giant storage shed for a bunch of shit
that you don't lead. Your apartment becomes the same way.
So if you downsize all of that to get out of a fucking job,
you don't want to be in and you reduce your fucking overhead in the meantime,
you can actually make less. You know,
there's all different ways to get out of the job, start spending less,
saving up fucking money so you can quit your job and live for four months
without having to fucking work or whatever, or making a little bit less money.
In the meantime,
just get rid of a bunch of shit that you don't even fucking need. Um,
I got to do that with the baby coming in any fucking day. Now I gotta uh,
I gotta get rid of a bunch of shit cause God knows she's going to have a bunch
of shit too, right? Uh,
I don't fucking know. Anyways, here we go. Let's fucking, let's,
let's plow ahead here. Uh, return gifts. Alright, dear bill,
I got to get into a debate with my fiance. I got into a debate with my fiance.
She seems to think it's rude. I don't wanna be rude.
It seems to be rude to ask someone for a gift receipt for a gift they did not
like.
Um,
I told her that it would be worse to keep the gift and never use it than to
return for a better size of something different. All together.
I take you for the type of guy to just say thank you and throw it out if you
don't like it. Good call man. I actually, if I don't like something,
I would never, I just don't do that. I just, uh, I take it down to goodwill.
Um, I got a jacket from my aunt that I don't like and doesn't fit.
She thinks I should just exchange it for a proper size and call it a day.
I know for a fact that my aunt wouldn't be offended because we're close enough
that I can tell her that thoughts on this, you know?
Okay.
This is one that I, it's up to you.
I think it's a good exercise to tell somebody what you're really feeling at the
price of their feelings. I just don't know if it's with a Christmas gift.
Um, [inaudible]
I think you can do it once to somebody, but if next year,
if they come back with something ugly again, then you're just saying,
you know, you have bad tastes. But, uh,
I don't think there's anything wrong with it.
I don't think there's anything wrong with it and a date. Look,
I gotta be honest with you. If I've got somebody a fucking gift right now,
if they didn't start screaming at me, make me sit down. Like if I ever got,
if I ever got my wife a gift, she was like, you know, I don't like this.
Can I exchange it? I'd be like, yeah, fuck yeah, absolutely. Here's the receipt.
Have Fun. Go into those crowded malls. I'm done.
I have fulfilled my end of the,
the verbal contractual agreement that we have that I will buy you a Christmas
gift. But you know, when you go to return the fucking thing, I mean,
that's on you. You can go back in there with all those fucking animals again.
I'm not doing it. Um, yeah, I don't think there's anything wrong with it.
I think a, that that's maybe that's a preference thing. You know,
if you want to fucking, do you want to go that route? You know, God bless Ya.
You go that fucking route. If you don't, I respect that too. Um,
all right. I slept my sister on Christmas Eve. I don't believe this.
I don't believe this at all. Dear Billy Bitch tits.
I'm bitch tits and you slapped a woman. Um, hey Billy.
Recently my family celebrated my dad's birthday, which is on Christmas Eve.
And like every year we went to a local Mexican restaurant.
My mother bought him a very expensive bottle of Middleton triple distilled Irish
whiskey. I'd never heard of that shit. Uh, I hope I said it right,
which we proceed to drink once we returned to my parents house. All right.
How many of you are on this bottle and there's a woman slapped in the end of
this? Jesus Christ. This is like a fucking country music video.
Once we were back,
my sister who's 30 asked if she could collect pictures of us as little kids,
she could make an album. I see.
I knew exactly where some great ones were of her as a baby and my mother's
drawer where she, my mother had previously shown me,
um, you know, I,
I don't know what's going to happen in this thing or if it's even a true story,
but I'm already saying at some point somebody should have said,
fair enough before somebody gets slapped with he goes,
my sister has a different father than I, and from what I gather,
her dad was a not so great guy and my mother doesn't seem to have any fun
memories of that relationship.
Okay.
Um, okay.
I presented the pictures to her expecting her to have either seen them before or
to be thrilled to be seeing them for the first time.
The pictures were of her and her father with my mother's family.
Um, I'm getting lost here. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Okay.
You guys have the same mom but different dads. Okay. Also,
her birth certificate was in the certificate was in the envelope,
which she apparently, which apparently she had never seen.
She's 30 she never had to produce a birth certificate. Once she saw them,
she freaked out.
She began to berate my mother for never showing them to her in a full blown
fight in suit. Of course, I was mortified.
I had no idea this was going to happen. Um, I'm going to go out on a limb here,
sir. When I say at this moment, this is not about you anymore. Okay. I mean,
she didn't have a good relationship with her dad. This could be, you know,
something that she needed or something that seems to be between her and her mom.
And if you're going to go third man in,
that's a game as conduct and I would say a fucking 10 game suspension,
at least a,
she said horribly hurtful things to my mother and tried to storm out once I
stepped in and tried to stop her. Oh Shit. Now you're doing that thing,
so need this product too. Fuck.
I'd make a zillion dollar the male or female.
Okay.
Person remover. Oh,
ignorant am I then I never thought that a woman ever had to fucking try to get
through the door with some fucking asshole guys. Dan,
my apology and all the ladies. All right. Once I stepped in and tried,
once I stepped in and tried to stop her,
she began to attack me and shout out everything that was wrong with me and my
life. I defended myself yelling back all the fucked up shit she's done.
Um, that's not defending yourself, sir.
What you did was you went to her emotional level,
which you should've done was just laid on the fucking ropes, let her go,
and then afterwards she would have owed you an apology. Uh, anyways,
so he goes then with Mike, this is,
this is why you don't go home for the holidays.
This shit always ends up happening. Then with my mother and father there,
she charged me and punched me square in the eye with this insane look on her
face while she wanted to leave. And you weren't letting her,
I was trying to keep her at arms length and telling myself over and over don't
hit her.
The final Straw came when with both my parents trying to hold her back,
she managed to kick me in the face with their boots on.
Okay,
aren't you standing up? How the fuck did she do that? Oh,
they held her back and Ted gave her leverage or is she like Anderson Silver and
she just gave you that front upkick that you didn't see whatever the fuck you
call it in MMA terms.
Then I proceeded calmly and coolly to pick the exact moment when to reach in and
give her an open palm slap right across the whole left side of her face.
You did that calmly and coolly. Oh, Jesus.
She immediately stopped at Tirade and went in her car to pout.
Wow. Have Dude. He slapped her in the face. I don't think she's pouting.
She laid chilled out and fell asleep on the sofa. Christmas being tomorrow.
I need your help.
Did I do the wrong thing and how can I keep things from being fucked up from
here on out. Thank you. Go Fuck Yourself. Did you do the wrong thing?
You slapped a woman? Yes. I mean, she's coming at you with a knife then. Yeah,
you can go close fist that at that point. But I mean,
all she was trying to do is leave. Um, here's the thing, dude. She had
oh,
a valid reaction to something that really hurt her in,
in her pain. She said a bunch of mean things to her mom.
All right? Now she comes from a broken home. I mean,
this shit's gonna happen during the fucking holidays.
You're fucking drunk on Whiskey, right? You guys a it, from what I can tell,
there's only two of you on that bottle, maybe three or whatever, but you know,
three, four people killing a bottle of whiskey, you're all going to be hammered.
All right? Um, then she wanted to leave.
Okay?
Now, if she's drunk and she wants to drive, that's one thing.
He did not put that in there. If she just wanted to leave to go beat by herself.
There's nothing more than when you're hurt and you're emotional.
You want to leave a room and people won't let you leave. It's fucking annoying.
All right? If she has no history of trying to hurt herself, she's not drunk.
You gotta let her leave. Um, the fact that you just said,
you calmly coolly waited for the fucking exact moment to reach in and slap her
across the face means you contemplated this shit.
It's like she hit you and then you reacted.
Um,
and did it, you made the decision, you thought about it and you waited for them.
So that point from like fucking second degree to first degree, um, so yeah, no,
you didn't do the right thing and you should,
I would feel terrible if I fucking did that.
Um,
and how can you stop things from being fucked up from here on out? Uh,
well I would sit down and I would just keep playing over and over again how it
escalated and you kind of zigged every time you should have zagged and just try
to think of what you can do the next time. But, uh,
calmly coolly picking the exact moment to slap your sister in the face on
Christmas Eve is
okay.
Yeah, I would say you did the wrong thing. I mean, like I said, literally,
unless she was literally going to be doing physical harm to a well,
I guess she hit you that God, that's so fucked up.
I'm not even thinking that she kicked you in the face and she did all of that
type of stuff. Um, I still gotta say,
cause they were holding her back.
It's just one of the things that women get to get away with. They get,
they get to get away with the salt veteran.
You see like you shouldn't fucking hit him.
But how fucked up is it that even as a guy,
I wasn't even validating the point that she kicked you in the face and a punched
you square in the eye with an insane look on her face.
I think it's very easily for me to be sitting here in bed,
not emotionally invested in any of this to say whether the fuck you did the
right thing or the wrong thing. Um, you know, you got a, a,
your family's gone through a fucked up time.
You throw alcohol in there and some old fucking pictures and uh,
you know,
okay.
Your sister, you know, puts her hands on you when you hit her back. I mean,
I don't know. I don't know. I would have to look
maybe cause you said you calmly and coolly picked the exact moment,
went to reach out. I Dunno. Maybe that's what fucking threw me off.
But like if this all went down and like fucking three seconds, uh, you know,
I think you guys all need some fucking group therapy. Um,
all I can say is I'm glad I wasn't there. I'm glad I wasn't at that party.
That's all I can say about that one. However,
I do feel that I owe you an apology for judging your actions without even taking
into consideration that you took two hits to the head, to the face.
You hit me in the face. Right. Um,
okay.
And you know,
I've see women like that and I know how hard they punch and kick and all that
shit and they have no concern
for the fact that they're wearing shoes and they kick you in the face.
So just said, you know, they weigh over a hundred pounds in,
who wants to get hit by somebody,
weighs a hundred pounds right in the fucking face. You don't,
and that the natural reaction to getting hit is to hit back and they got that
whole, well, cause I'm a girl, you can't do it yet. I can just fucking,
okay.
Break all the fucking rules in the, you know, it's, it's,
it's one of the things, but you know, something I,
okay.
Maybe that's just one of the, one of the perks you get for being a woman,
you know, they got to have their period every month.
They got to go through fucking labor. You know what I mean?
They got to get all those free drinks.
They always get the house during the divorce. I mean,
there's a lot of things that they have to go through that maybe,
maybe it's okay that they can hit us. I have no fucking idea. Um,
all I know is that, you know, if a woman ever hits you, you just,
you just fucking walk away. You just walk away. And, um,
if they're not related to you, you just end the relationship like this is over.
Yeah. You know, what are you coming back to ut and get me a gift now?
Where am I? I'm like the battered woman now and I'm like, oh wait,
she's usually not like that. She shuts a good for to go fuck yourself over.
Um, all right, so what I do a five. Okay. Did I do the wrong thing? And it can,
how can I keep things from being fucked up from here on out? Okay.
This is what the first thing you do.
I would not drink whiskey around volatile family members. Uh,
I wouldn't do that. I would try to be the sober person.
I think if you were more sober, I probably wouldn't have done that.
Or at the very least she would have saw the punch coming.
Sounded like she threw a straight right. You know,
should've made a little slip that, you know,
yes,
I'm fucking with you. Sorry that that happened. And uh, you know, I dunno,
you guys had kind of evened out. She hit you twice. You only hit her once.
And maybe that's fair. Who the fuck knows? I don't fucking know, but I, I don't,
I don't buy into that whole chivalry thing that, you know,
that once somebody starts swinging on you, it's, they've, they've,
they've fucking, you know,
they've waived all rights of chivalry and, uh,
and rules between the sexist in my own opinion, but like, it's the fat. It's,
but for the guy though is his, if he reacts immediately, I give you a pass.
But the fact that you thought about it, it, she'll still come back to,
even though she deserves it, she still a lady and then you don't, I mean,
personally, I could, I could, uh, well I guess she never say never,
but I've never run into that. And I've had a lot of women hit me. I mean,
I'm an asshole. I've had a lot of women hit me. Uh,
I've had women throw shit at me. Um,
but it's never a, it's never gotten to that point where I, I w I,
I couldn't do that. She's a,
it's like hitting a fucking kid or a dog or some shit, you know? I couldn't,
I couldn't do it like an animal. The defenseless, you know what I mean?
Unless it's like Rhonda Rousey, who's fighting this fucking weekend?
Everybody you know that fuck. If you, if your, there's a question for you.
You're dating someone who is not just takes karate or fucking MMA shit is
actually in the UFC. Then what does that become?
You know what I mean?
If she fucking hits you and say, you serve five that
okay.
Oh God.
There's not a woman who's even remotely thought about getting into the UFC.
That couldn't kick the shit out of me.
I can't imagine fighting one that was actually in the UFC and be fucking
hilarious. Then later they're apologizing is I have a stake over my eye.
I'll make it up to your freckles. All right.
Ex-Girlfriend is a cunt.
Jesus fucking James Blunt here.
Ex-Girlfriend is a cunt. Hey Bill.
I am a lady and a huge fan of yours.
I love Nia as well. Uh,
get her on the case if possible, please.
Oh well she's still downstairs sleeping. Okay.
I dig other ladies and recently I broke up.
I broke a very important relationship in my life.
I was dating this girl on and off for many years and felt totally in love with
her. Um,
all the while she claimed she loved me more than anything. Uh,
which she still does claim by the way, by the way, and says,
I am the only person she has ever wanted to spend your life with. However,
she's one of these people who just needs her freedom and can't function in a
fucking relationship. Well, then you got to let her go. Uh, before we broke up,
we had this huge fucking argument about commitment and I said,
I didn't see the point in continuing this relationship.
She reflected on it and said, I was absolutely right.
That I don't deserve to dedicate my entire life to someone as complicated as
her. Well, yeah, I agree with her and walk. I agreed.
She then said she tried but can't reciprocate my feelings in the same intensity.
All right.
That was eight years before this broad was jerking me around saying I'm the love
of her life, and she wanted to marry me and live with me forever.
All these years. Every time I confronted her about her troublesome behavior,
it was never cheating. At least a, she didn't tell me, hey,
I don't think our feelings match. This may not work.
She led me to believe she loved me enough. Uh,
she's still saying I'm the love of her life and whatnot,
but feels horrible for all the pain she's caused me and the time I wasted.
I said, being in love,
the love of her life wasn't enough to make her act like a good girlfriend.
And then I wanted to move on with my life. So we parted ways. Good for you.
Strong move. I like that move. Now I'm not sure what to do, where to start.
My identity is so intertwined with this intertwined with this person and how we
used to be in the beginning. I want to start over,
but I don't know who I am outside of this relationship.
I like to hear your thoughts about it because I think you guys give some good
advice. All right. I would say this, what you're feeling is totally normal.
And what a lot of people do is when they feel those feelings of like,
well now what do I do? Who am I? How do I pick up the fucking pieces?
There is that initial feeling,
which does not feel good and your natural reaction is to go for the quickest
fix, which is to go back into that fucking horrible relationship,
which you have to do as the song goes. You've got to walk through the fire here.
I would write down, you know, I started journaling something so you can kind of,
you know,
it's something to just be feeling your thoughts versus writing them down and
then you can see them and then you can kind of get outside of yourself,
which is what you need right now. And you know, friends help with this too.
We have to be like, look, you can't go back to this person. You know that.
Okay. But right now is like,
the worst part is now you're going to be lonely in a heartbroken by yourself and
this person that usually comfort you is the cause of it's,
you can't go to them for comfort cause it's gonna fuck you all up and get you
back to square one. So, um, um,
you're asking me what you should do is I think that you should
acknowledge the fact that you're going to, you have to go through some pain.
You're going to go through some pain over the next like, you know,
certainly three months.
But what you do during that time is you gradually build a new life without this
person.
So the first month you're going to be in the fetal position crying and just,
you know, going through the next tool,
the psycho to detox of this person.
But what I would try to do is introduce a new fun activity.
You know, that you could do like, I don't know, whatever the fuck is into,
even if it's like a fucking TV show that you meant to binge watch.
Something as simple as that. That is something that you do.
And in that it's yours that you don't do with this other person.
And then you just introduce something else little when you ready for something
else. Maybe you always want to learn how to ride a horse. Go fucking do that.
God knows you got the Goddamn time, something fun,
but there's something that you've always wanted to do,
but she didn't have the time with work and being involved in a relationship.
Go do that fucking thing. Take a trip, do something.
And all the time when you're feeling sad,
give into the sadness and cry some of that fucking pain out.
I'm a big believer in crying. Um,
it's something that guys are not allowed to do.
It's why women get passionate and guys carry shit.
Women still can look back and see the sadness,
but they're done feeling fucked up over cause they didn't hold onto the emotion.
They let the emotion out. Guys hold the fucking thing and like,
I believe that guys should, you know,
cause it's too embarrassing for people to see us cry.
They should in every house, the way you have a bathroom, a bedroom, a kitchen,
there should be a crying room for the man. He goes into,
closes a door, it's soundproof. And he's allowed to go in there,
in whale out all of his fucking pain, the way women are,
and everyone flocks to them and hugs them and gives them comfort. And uh,
you know, I'm a big believer in it now than after,
after half a century of holding it in.
I believe that you should fucking let it out.
You should go Chris Bosch if you're a guy. Um,
so that's what I would say to you and just acknowledge the fact that this is
going to hurt. I'm proud of you that you got out of this relationship, you know,
eight years of this person jerking you around and you know what you did.
You got out of something toxic and you opened the door for the right person to
come into your life.
You know some that's gonna respect you and make you laugh and you'll have a
great time, you know, and one day you're gonna look back on,
what the fuck did I waste eight years with that person.
You know why you did so you could realize how great the person that's going to
come into life is going to be. And there you go. There's your pep talk.
All right, you can do it. I believe in you. All right, here we go.
Let's read the last two fucking ads here and then I got to get the folk atty.
Alright. Um, oh, blue apron. Everybody. Hey is something you could do.
By the way, the person who just,
I just read because one of the things you might want you might do is, uh,
eat a bunch of food and put on fucking weight. You don't want to do that.
You know,
that's like another being another bad fucking thing that this person created.
They broke your heart.
Now they're going to fucking put more stress on your heart because you're going
to eat bad food. You know,
it'd be great to think is he ate healthy meals and you know what? You're crying.
You're in the fetal position.
Would it be great if somebody just brought the food to you? Blue Apron.
This is like the fucking that this is the best move you can make.
If you go through a breakup right here, blue apron,
they're going to bring your healthy food. It's easy to fucking cook.
You're going to stay in shape, right as you get over that fucking last asshole.
A client that was in your fucking life and a, you gonna be in good shape.
Does baby attracting somebody else in your life? Who knows,
but do not just jump into something. I forgot that part of the advice.
Do not jump into another fucking relationship.
I would stay after an eight year thing.
You need to stay single for at least a fucking year.
I would think a and that'll make you so fucking strong. You, you, you,
you'll be looking back on. I can't believe I used to be that other person. Okay,
blue apron. Not all ingredients are created equal, fresh,
high quality ingredients. Make a real difference.
So it's an important to know where you food comes from. Uh,
it's affordable for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes along with proportion and Greens to make
delicious home cooked meals.
Choose from a variety of new recipes each week or let blue aprons culinary team
surprise you. Recipes are not repeated within a year,
so you're never going to get bored. And it's flexible. Customize your rest,
your recipes each week based on your preferences.
Blue Apron has several delivery options so you choose what fits your needs and
there's no weekly commitment. Uh, so you only get deliveries when you want them.
Each meal comes with step-by-step,
easy to follow recipe card and pre portion degrees and can be prepared in 40
minutes or less. Blue aprons, freshness guarantees, promise,
promises that every ingredient in your delivery arrives. Ready to cook.
All right, here we go. This is,
I get check out this week's menu and get your first three meals for free with
free shipping by going to blue apron.com/burr. Uh,
that's blue apron.com/burr blue apron. A better way to cook. And lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com you don't have time to go to the post office post
office. So what do you do?
I use stamps.com instead with stamps.com you can avoid all the hassle man of
going to the post office during the busy holiday season.
Then the mailman picks it up.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters when I'm on the road.
Trust me if I'm a moron, if I can figure it out. So can you,
it's that easy right now. Um,
I can get you a better offer from stamps.com and what's on the home page.
Sign up for the,
for a stamps.com and use my last name borough to get a four week trial plus $110
bonus offer, including postage and a digital scale. Go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone at the top of the homepage.
Type in Burr that stamps.com enter Byrd. All right,
that's the podcast for this week. Enjoy, um,
between the Christmas Hanukkah, Kwanzaa in the new years.
Uh, that's it. Go fuck yourselves. Then I'll check in on you on Thursday.